SPEAKER 1: My friend Kelsey
Hightower once said, containers
are the price of admission
to using Kubernetes.
So to get started
with Kubernetes,
we'll need to dive deeper into
what containers really are.
With a whole universe
of things to learn,
it's important to start
with the essentials.
Let's go over the
concepts that make
Kubernetes usable, scalable,
and just downright awesome.
Are you ready?
So Kubernetes is a
container orchestrator.
Last time you said
that containers
were packaged up services.
What does that actually mean?
SPEAKER 2: Yeah,
containers were built
to deploy smaller services
with isolation and consistency.
But they're not
actually a new concept.
Containers are based on
some underlying concepts
from the Linux kernel--
Namespaces and Cgroups.
SPEAKER 1: Right,
Namespaces make sure
that individual
processes can't see
the details of other processes.
And Cgroups control how
much resources a process
can use, like CPU memory.
SPEAKER 2: These
two concepts are all
about giving a
process isolation,
protecting it from interfering
with other processes,
as well as protecting
itself from others.
SPEAKER 1: Virtual machines
can give us a similar level
of isolation, but only by
packing the whole operating
system with it.
For plenty of applications,
the OS isn't necessary.
And it certainly takes
up a lot of resources.
Containers, on the
other hand, only focus
on the application
and its dependencies,
making them more lightweight.
Now apps don't
need to worry about
if some developer had hard-coded
Python 2.7 into the path
variable.
SPEAKER 2: That's an
oddly specific example.
But yes.
There's actually a few
different container run times.
But one of the most
popular is Docker.
They built an API that helped
app developers build containers
and a platform to run them the
same way regardless of which
machine they run on.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
It's all about letting the app
developer define what they want
the runtime to look like instead
of spending time messing around
with the kernel.
This is all done
in a Docker file.
Why don't we zoom in on one?
SPEAKER 2: Good idea.
If you were working
on a simple Flask app,
your Docker file
might look like this.
The first line is the base
image the app should use.
You can choose from all
sorts of base images.
So you can choose one
that has exactly what you
need with less overhead,
making your container smaller.
SPEAKER 1: Next, these
lines so the container
what commands to run
when being initialized.
Your Flask app is definitely
going to need Python.
So this installs
Python, Pip, and Flask.
SPEAKER 2: Now the
Copy command will
grab files from your
local environment
and copy them into
the container.
So your local app.py file
gets copied to /opt/app.py.
And the container now
has your app files.
SPEAKER 1: And finally,
the Entry Point command
lets your container
run as an executable,
actually starting up
the Flask application.
With just a few lines,
you've created a container.
SPEAKER 2: Awesome, but--
SPEAKER 1: But?
SPEAKER 2: But you
would still have
to manually deploy
the container,
manage it, and handle situations
like if the container goes down
or if you want to roll out
an upgrade to your app code.
SPEAKER 1: And now we've
come back to Kubernetes.
Kubernetes takes care of
managing your containers,
no matter if you
have one or 1,000.
Just like how your
Docker file explains
what you want your
container to do,
you can configure
Kubernetes for what you
want your whole cluster to do.
You might hear this
called the desired state.
SPEAKER 2: And that's
probably the coolest thing
about Kubernetes.
You tell it what the desired
state for the cluster is,
and it automates everything from
pods, nodes, to load balancers,
and more.
SPEAKER 1: Whoa.
Hold on.
That's a lot of new stuff.
Let's start with the essentials.
We were just talking
about containers.
So what's a pod?
SPEAKER 2: A pod is
like a collection
of multiple containers, sort
of a pseudo-application.
It could just be
one app, or it could
be multiple different ones
that need to work together.
For example, let's go
back to your Flask app.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
So I know how to
build a container.
How do we turn this into a pod?
SPEAKER 2: Well, if
that's your desired state,
we can tell Kubernetes
to make it happen.
Here's a YAML file that gives
the desired state for a pod.
This metadata section
gives a way for Kubernetes
to group pods and other
resources together.
And we'll dive deeper
into that later.
For now, the key part
is this Spec section.
SPEAKER 1: Here's
where you name the pod
and tell it which image to use.
Since this is a simple pod.
Your container is the
only one running here.
There's also a port
section so the container
can be accessed through the
web on the default ACT port 80.
SPEAKER 2: Once this config is
put into a Kubernetes cluster,
Kubernetes knows
what you want to do
and is in charge of ensuring
that your actual state matches
your desired state.
SPEAKER 1: That's a
great start, but where is
the pod actually going to run?
SPEAKER 2: For that,
we'll need to talk more
about nodes and deployments.
Let's cover that in
the next episode.
SPEAKER 1: Sounds good.
So today, we covered
more about containers
and why they became so popular.
SPEAKER 2: Then we started
to talk about how Kubernetes
works with containers.
But there's still
plenty more to cover.
SPEAKER 1: Wow.
That was a lot of great
info on containers.
But now, we need to
figure out how they run.
Stay tuned, everybody.
If you want to get
hands on, check out
the link in the description.
And if you enjoyed the
episode, subscribe for more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]